I started watching a lot of pornography,
the pornography that I was watching had
to fit in with that.
I can't just watch anything.
I,
I became very limited to watching a very
specific type and I read the book,
the brain that changes itself by Dr.
no dot.
I could see that exactly.
And I.
So even though I knew that the more
times you give in your building up the
circuitry and the last times you give in
your getting better.
I just,
I've had issues with that.
So that's what I've recently done that
I,
I've stopped watching pornography for
about a month now.
Okay.
So let,
let me ask you about that because you
know,
there's a,
there's a big undergrown conversation
about pornography that's happening on
the web,
you know,
and with,
with many man and it's hard to tell how
many deciding to stop using pornography.
And you know,
I've made some comments publicly about
pornography use being,
let's call it sub optimal,
you know,
because it.
Well,
because it,
I think that it,
it isn't good for the women who were
involved in it and it's not good for
young men because it's,
it's too,
it gives you access to something,
gives you access to part of something,
but denies you access to all of it.
And I think it's dangerous because of
that,
because it,
it offers immediate gratification,
but no.
Well that's it.
It offers immediate gratification,
but no medium to longterm development of
character or life.
I guess that's it.
And,
and that seems to be a dangerous kind of
trap.
And the other thing is that it's also A.
Norman has talked about this Dr Doidge.
No,
it's,
we don't know what that kind of massive
exposure to multiple virtual sex
partners and,
and,
and does two to the development of the
sexual sexual behavior and sexual
gratification and sexual impulse in
relationship in,
in young men at all.
So it's a technological,
technological marvel that's very
dangerous I would say,
or at least it has the potential to be.
So what do you think the pornography use
did to you and what utility,
if any,
has there been in stopping?
I found that,
well it's just,
that's one issue that I've had or have a
major issue that I've had in many
different facets,
has been looking for instant
gratification.
So for me it's been food,
marijuana,
TV in pornography and I just found that
my thoughts would be always just looking
for one of those and it in,
as soon as they experience was over
your,
you'd have just had this little quick
release where you feel good and then
back in pain.
And I've sort of realized that my
pleasure was just getting rid of pain,
like pain and pleasure are two sides,
sides of the same coin.
And I was just flipping the same coin
over and over and how I felt now without
doing it.
Well,
when I first decided stop,
uh,
I thought I'd try writing down every
time a thought came to watch pornography
and I,
I couldn't believe it the first day.
Like it seemed like almost like once a
minute.
Like I just have a thought saying watch
it,
watch it.
And my thoughts would try to trick me
and say,
oh,
but just by observing,
and I don't know what you think about
this,
but what I would do is when I get the
thought to do it,
I,
I bite down on my thumb in one
particular spot and then I found that
the next few days the thoughts were just
coming less and less.
And now that it's been a month,
I rarely have the thought.
And the benefits I find is that I just
feel so much more aware and I'm not
seeking pleasure as much.
I'm just enjoying going,
going for walks and being in nature.
Hmm.
Well,
you know,
your,
your report is,
is really quite reminiscent of an
addiction actually because,
and you mentioned this and you did a
good job of explaining it.
You know,
if you.
If you engage in a behavior and then
it's followed by a burst of pleasure,
like an orgasmic release,
then that behavior is going to be
powerfully reinforced and the circuitry
that that drives you to,
that behavior is going to become
dominant because behavior that
culminates in a reward tends to become
stronger.
And that includes attitudes and ideas
and thoughts and impulses and
rationalizations,
you know,
of exactly the sort that you were
describing.
Then you said that it really plagued
badly for the first day or two and then
started to decrease quite precipitously
after that.
And that's,
that's a good example of how behavior
extinguishes if you cease rewarding it.
So,
and what does that freed you up to do
and what do you think that's going to do
in terms of your willingness or ability
to pursue longterm a longterm
relationship?
Yup.
For Free Time,
uh,
made a schedule after watching your,
your personality lectures and I just,
I have obviously I have a lot more time
on my hands to,
to do those things.
Um,
and in terms of finding a partner since
I've been back in Canada,
I haven't even for a lot of times I
haven't approached women because I just
feel that no matter what it leads to
just have difficulties.
On one occasion there was a girl who was
hitting on me and we went on a couple
dates and it went great.
She was attracted to me.
I was attracted to her,
we had a great time,
but when it came time to be intimate,
adjust,
I was shaking like a leaf,
like I just because I was so used to
using the same stimulus of imagining,
I had a very strict thing that I can
imagine in my mind.
I don't know what most people,
for most guys,
what they have to think of when they
watch pornography.
I had to imagine entire backstory
because I had this issue with trust
because of what happened.
I think,
okay,
where are we?
Why did we meet?
What's going to happen after like I.
So because of all that I've just sort of
been avoiding it.
Um,
well.
So let me ask you a question.
Like I'd been trying to figure out what
reasonable guidelines might be with
regards to initiating sexual activity
with a new partner.
And it seems to me that you probably
shouldn't initiate anything that you
wouldn't talk to the person about
because what that might mean is that you
don't know them well enough to go that
far with them physically.
And there's dangers in that.
You outlined some of them,
you know,
I mean sex is powerful and it can,
especially when you're inexperienced,
it can hurt you and hurt can be,
you know,
long term or permanent and that's kind
of what you're relating.
And so one of the things that I might
suggest is that when you initiate the
next relationship that you.
I mean,
I'm not saying that this is an easy
thing to do because it's not,
but it's,
there's nothing wrong with not moving
forward sexually until you've been able
to discuss what your life personally in
relationship to sexual behavior,
you know,
like because you might say,
well maybe you shouldn't be engaging in
intimate behavior with a person before
you can tell them the story about what
happened to you and in the South Pacific
and lay out your personal history and be
comfortable with that.
You know,
that seems to me that sort of emotional
intimacy seems to be the proper
precursor to physical intimacy.
And I know that our culture has pushed
really hard probably since about the
year or since about the emergence of the
birth control pill.
It's pushed pretty hard on this idea
that casual sex is first of all
possible,
that it can be casual and also
desirable,
but I think that that.
I think that that's a big mistake.
I don't believe either of those.
I don't think that there is such a thing
as casual sex and I don't think that
it's desirable.
I think it causes people a lot more
trouble than they realize.